I
you're a gamer first thing that you
thought when you heard about the
resurgence of virtual reality is likely
when do I get to play a shooter now for
a while we thought this wasn't gonna be
a good idea holding a controller in your
hands and spinning and moving at the
same time is one of the prime causes of
what they call simulator sickness but
with the arrival of handheld controllers
like the ones coming with a consumer
high-end VR devices oculus rift and the
HTC vive and even PlayStation VR we're
finding the ability to unlock genres of
games that we didn't think we're gonna
be possible one of the companies working
on that is Servius which brought its
forthcoming game raw data our way last
week we got to jump in and give it a
spin so the question is what's it like
feeling like an action hero the answer
is not so bad now rock data is is
basically a co-op shooter mixed with a
tower defense game you and your partner
are stuck in the middle of this
underground base trying to fight off
waves of robots as they come at you
what's most notable about this is we're
finally getting away from the Xbox
controller which was kind of the default
way we played VR games up until this
consumer released this spring this is
everything that Nintendo tried to do
with motion control everything
any game developer is done with making a
first-person game more immersive this
creates and because your movements
matter because the physical component of
this game matters you're translating
your real-world reflexes and your
real-world aim to this should warn you
though there are some occupational
hazards with being a spectator not
saying that I punched a producer while
he was filming this but I totally
punched a producer while he was filming
it oh oh so if you're gonna have friends
come over to play the game or watch play
the game they may want to keep their
distance just remember if you get the
vibe get rid of all the furniture in
your living room and get ready to waste
some robots